this is the world's largest tnt
explosion this entire map is tnt we are
literally going to break tnt world
records in this video gentlemen this is
ikea tower go hide in it okay ah
i'm stuck gentlemen i'm gonna spawn 25
tnt let's see if you survive
oh whoa
you survived yay
now we're on pewdiepie's house and i'm
gonna spawn 50 tnt 50 again i want you
guys to try to survive and this time
i'll give your mom a hundred dollars i
need this hey carl look up
are you guys ready i don't care the tnt
spot oh
[Music]
all right
oh he died oh oh jayla done i did it
wait carl how did you survive i i kind
of just sat in this little pocket here's
100 give it to your mom okay now we have
a lamborghini and i'm going to spawn 75
tnt oh no i'm very afraid why is he like
glowing and stuff look at me did you eat
a capital yes chandler you are now in
prison for attempting to cheat let me
out of this jail if you survive this 75
tnt i'll give your mom 500
yo my mom needs that do you guys like
where you are i'm in the trunk no
who cares i spawned the tnt 75 tnt will
you survive oh one spun on top of me
what yeah there's no you guys just don't
care about your mobs how did i die wait
you died back there
was out of jail when he died now we're
gonna see if this giant bus can survive
a hundred tnt what is your guys's plans
on this bus i'm gonna hide in this
i have a plan
you're inside the bus are you ready to
win five hundred dollars for your mama
i'm ready get out of the way chris
carl what the hell too bad all right the
tnt spawn oh i can see chris through the
window
oh i'm dead oh you all died next one for
this round instead of giving your mom
money if you die you get a punishment
wait we have to get punished what's the
punishment you have to eat milk duds no
one likes milk duds no
carl's on top chandler's on the butter
shell what about chris were you hiding
all right i've got my spot all right
you're on the back 250 t versus the
fridge
oh what do you see
oh carl you're dead carl's dead
[Music]
chiller
survived it spawned on top of me what
was i supposed to do
that's what they're getting dumped in my
mouth we are now on a giant construction
site and we're gonna drop 400 tnt this
time okay all right and this time you
guys will be competing for an xbox one
oh oh my god i needed something to hold
my door i'm gonna throw a thousand
dollars in on top of it for your moms oh
let's go
but you only have ten seconds to hide go
five
four
three i'm kind of bored blowing it up
they spun beside me
um
i died do you guys hate xbox ones that
much you guys are now on a giant plane i
didn't notice i'm gonna spawn 1000 tnt
and if you survive i'll give your mom a
high five buy a high five i mean five
thousand dollars jimmy we're in discord
with you five five thousand dollars i've
made a high five
i light this candle i'm trying to give
mama some money 1 000 tnt
oh they're right beside me if you
survive your mama gets rich
oh
i almost survived no
no
no i did it i actually did it the plane
exploded and you survived yeah all right
here's five thousand dollars
i'm literally about to just call my mom
tonight and let her know she just got
five grand she's gonna be so confused we
are now on the pyramid of chandler man
upgraded from an island to a whole
pyramid it might be hard to tell because
the book bag and the money are green but
this is a book bag full of money how
much we talking i don't know i just
shoved it in the bag i like that amount
and whoever survives gets it go hide on
the pyramid he's going to my mama done
hiding wait you're hiding on top yes
saves me money gentlemen are you ready
sure i guess everyone if you wouldn't
mind please look up in the sky oh my
gosh it's a nuke oh
what coming right from my head
no
no i didn't water bucket please please
please
oh yeah
yes oh no i wanted to put bag though
let's keep going i gotta just play with
this in my lap now now we're gonna do
100 000 tnt versus this castle
and whoever survives this one gets a
briefcase full of money for their father
oh
all right everyone go hide i'm gonna
fake like i'm not hiding and then boom
i'm gonna get in the water and be safe i
think it'll try to blast me upward in
which i will land and water bucket like
a pro all right i'm ready ready do all
of you have a good hiding place in the
castle i'm in a little hidey hole i'm in
the courtyard well i don't care dropping
another nuke this is a hundred thousand
tnt nuke
a nuke i can't even see it oh
no way we're going to survive
oh how did i fall for my place
yo this duke is huge the ground got
deleted the entire thing is gone this is
like a domino's xl pizza i'm about to
unleash a black hole equivalent to 1
million tnt there's no way we're gonna
survive and what better place to do that
than a remake of nuketown the pyramid
was a book bag full of money and the
winner of this gets a fishbowl full of
money i like fish actually all i have
left was a fishbowl where'd you put the
fish chandler do you have a place yet um
no okay well i just dropped it everyone
look up look oh black hole what oh my
god what the heck it's coming down oh
boy i hear it what are we gonna do i
don't know just don't die it's like
eating the earth jesus wait carl your
strap might work no it's not oh
get me out of here oh i'm dying
oh i died of radiation i just spawned
and died it's still going we're still
dying the aftermath is so crazy it's not
even loading for me i fell through the
map oh wait it is loading it just broke
the bedrock it broke bedrock but you
can't break bedrock you guys are
currently standing on 10 million blocks
of tnt i'm standing on a wall block and
the winner of this one gets a duffel bag
full of money the rules are there are no
rules whoever dies last gets the double
back full money
whoever dies last we're checking chat
logs
i'm lagging i'm lagging i'm lagging the
entire game just stopped from it chris
died oh i'm dead it's going out like one
frame at a time but it looks like it's
coming towards carl and chandler no
i'm not even on the thingy anymore look
at this tnt creator get me out get me
out oh my game crash if you check chat
chris is the only one that's died
apparently a minecraft server can't
handle 10 million tnt hello there carl
hi you and chandler were both alive when
the server crashed and we need to decide
who gets the ten thousand dollars in
this duffel bag sure i'll take it if you
select the split block and chandler
[ __ ] to split block you both get five
grand if you select split and he selects
steel he gets the 10 grand and if you
both pick steel neither of you get it
yeah what you gonna do do you trust
chandler place your decision right here
really right now place your decision
which is it
i i have faith in him so you're gonna
split it i trust him honestly do you
think carl chose to split it with you or
steal it from you he's so sneaky i
thought you guys were friends though
what if he put a green block down and
you put a red block down and just took
the 10 grand for yourself
okay oh let's do it before we tear down
the wall what do you think chandler
picked carl i don't know i believe in
him server dropped the walls
carl i'm sorry
but chandler stole 10 dollars from you
nerd
chris misled me i was easily influenced
here is a duffel bag buddy here's a fat
snack
oh look at me
just look at me
no harm no foul
and what better way to end this video
than an entire world made up of tnt jeez
and we're going to start this historic
explosion with chad the turtle oh not
chad chad play the outro music
[Music]
server crash